imagine closing your eyes to everything
around you and opening them again on a
tropical beach once the stuff of fantasy
now virtual reality perfect beach is the
creation of a British game developer n
dreams the company focuses exclusively
on virtual world games it's considered a
pioneer in the construction of animated
3d landscapes the the biggest difference
is in developing for VR is the fact that
the the player can look at everything
we've made from every angle every
imaginable possible angle and previously
when we used to make games for standard
monitors you could get away with taking
parts out or hiding the you know the
reverse side of an object so now we have
to be a little bit more smart and how we
do things where that's concerned n
dreams latest game is a thriller called
the assembly players make their way
through the virtual world by simply
moving their eyes or the old-fashioned
way by joystick the impression of three
dimensions is created by two slightly
different images in the virtual reality
glasses display the players brain
reassembles the images in 3d creating
the illusion of actually being present
in the animated world n dreams CEO
patrick allu na has no doubt that this
is the future of video gaming we just
fell in love with VR we love the feeling
of presence the feeling that you're
teleported to another world the thing
about VR that makes it so special is
that you're you're not a spectator
looking from from outside you're in the
action you're looking around you
actually feel like you're there and that
makes things like emotions very powerful
fear and happiness and excitement and
all sorts of other emotions are much
stronger and they are so that's the
reason that we fell in love in it he and
his coworkers are hoping gamers in
Germany and elsewhere will fall in love
with virtual reality as well hundreds of
thousands of them have descend
cologne for gamescom the world's largest
computer and video games trade fair many
are willing to stand in line for hours
to catch a glimpse of the latest
releases
lava being from alex berg is a dedicated
gamer she comes to cologne every year to
try out the latest innovations but this
is the first time she's ever tried
virtual reality glasses
this is what's called lead analyst it's
something completely new I play video
games on the pc myself so this kind of
game is a stark contrast you can look
around in every direction after a while
it puts quite a strain on your eyes I
get a headache really fast this feeling
is always there the graphics just aren't
advanced enough yet this is all
phonographic northeastern biggie but
gaming is only one potential application
for virtual reality glasses the
university of regensburg institute of
psychology is exploring the use of
virtual worlds as a therapeutic tool
here patients learn to overcome their
fear of heights criminologists to have
been experimenting with VR simulations
the University of Zurich Institute of
Forensic Medicine compiles data to
reconstruct crime scenes in 3d
investigators can then walk through it
using virtual reality glasses the
head-mounted displays and graphics are
not perfect just yet but teams at the
likes of Sony HTC oculus rift and German
optical systems maker size are working
feverishly to put out a marketable pair
of VR glasses so what comes next
asian people altars in ruins the entire
business myself included is certain that
this is no flash in the pan how fast we
can make a real success of virtual
reality glasses depends on the price and
whether there will be cheaper
entry-level models i psycho mode le I'm
convinced there will be and how fast
convincing game worlds are developed for
them foodie thy table and heaved it's
only a matter of time before VR glasses
are ready for the mass market the makers
still have to work out how to prevent
motion sickness but the first displays
are set to hit the stores within months
until then we'll just have to put up
with everyday reality